we're in a massive process of de norming
we are unraveling every standard in the
name of racial justice so what happened
in your car that's that's a product of
largely of proposition 47 one of the
ballot initiatives in California that
downgraded a whole bunch of felonies
including felony theft to misdemeanor
status because of the problem of
criminal laws having a disparate impact
on minorities do you think it's funny
that the the billionaires that are
thought of as the good guy billionaire
so you know Bill Gates is thought of as
good let's say Warren Buffett is thought
of as good you know Koch brothers bad or
whoever the right ones are bad but the
ones that are thought it was good they
sort of think that they can give away
enough money or say enough things that
it will save them but it will never save
them right in the eye ultimately of the
base no matter they could give away
everything they can destroy their
fortunes and empires and it just it will
never end yeah and there's things I just
don't realize that or it's like you just
have to do it no matter what because you
want to survive do they not realize it
yeah I don't really have a choice but
they are playing with fire I mean they
have to realize that the extent that
they continue feeding this and Marc
Benioff is just a great example there he
is in in San Francisco promoting this
idea that the San Francisco is not done
enough to help the homeless and you know
we need to save the children and whatnot
through just endless bulking up of the
bureaucracy without dealing with the
profound questions of norms public norms
of behavior you know he probably thinks
he can buy exoneration but it's just
it's not going to happen because again
it's all connected
you know this the same left that is has
been dominating homeless politics in San
Francisco for decades the Coalition on
homelessness they are connected to the
entire woke discourse whether it's
regards to it
aliens or you know white supremacy or
male toxic masculinity it's all it's all
part of the same thing so let's shift
actually towards the the homeless
portion of monkeys I watched this
morning a talk that you did about the
San Francisco situation which everyone
knows is horrific I've told this story a
million times but when I was there about
a year ago I went out to dinner with a
friend and we were at Morton's
Steakhouse so it's a nice Street we're
on supposedly nice Street our car got
broken into right outside the restaurant
they stole my bag and my notebook and
all this stuff and I took a picture of
the broken glass and I tweeted it out
and I kid you not I got hundreds if not
thousands of responses basically all
saying the same thing Dave what kind of
idiot
leaves a bag in a car in San Francisco
because there is such an epidemic of
break-ins that they know that regular
people know not to leave a bag in a car
yeah what is happening up there
well it's happening across the country
we're in a massive process of de norming
we are unraveling every standard in the
name of racial justice so what happened
in your car that's that's a product of
largely of proposition 47 one of the
ballot initiatives in California that
downgraded a whole bunch of felonies
including felony theft to misdemeanor
status because of the problem of
criminal laws having a disparate impact
on minorities do you think the people
that are pushing these laws that it's
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions always do you think that they
really think they're doing something
good even though all the evidence always
points to the fact that it gets worse
after these policies yeah I don't I
don't I I think I've you've said
yourself you're not a big fan of
conspiracy theories I'm not either
I really I take people at their word I
think that they really do believe that
the over-representation of blacks in
prison is due to criminal justice racism
and that we're throwing a whole bunch of
trivial offenders in prison which is not
the case you have to work very hard to
get yourself a prison sentence most any
big city or
gosh doubt you you know if you steal
somebody's car a DA is gonna be
completely uninterested in you you have
to steal it at gunpoint with the drivers
still in to get a big-city DA interested
in actually prosecuting your case as
opposed to just giving you probation and
sending you on your way but no I think
that they they really do believe that
the criminal justice system is racist
and that the way to solve that is to is
to not prosecute not put people not and
defang the police and of course the
problem is yes there's a vast
over-representation of blacks in prison
but the thing we should be concerned
about is that blacks are victimized by
crime the most and I go to community
meetings in in inner-city neighborhoods
all the time those good law-abiding
bourgeois residents of high crime
neighborhoods beg for more police
protection those are the voices that
never get heard so when these policies
are put in place or like in New York
City the Blasio is now done this thing
where you're allowed to jump the
turnstile they will not stop you so it's
like you're basically saying to
everybody that pays yeah right and I
lived in New York City most of my adult
life I never jumped a turnstile you're
basically saying if you pay you're an
idiot yeah like why should you do it and
so they're actually encouraging more and
more people to not follow the law I know
an AOC has as well I mean this is really
for a politician to defend turnstile
jumping should be that's an impeachable
offense because social norms are fragile
mm-hmm and respect for the for the rule
of law is the essence of a civilization
we lose that and you get third world
anarchy with everybody trying to game
the system
you know queueing is a thing of beauty
we take it for granted but for people to
be able to quietly wait in line and wait
their place as opposed to trying to you
know get to the top and just muscle
everybody else out break the rules
whatever to get ahead that is a you know
it's been a sort of normal condition and
for respect for the rule of for the
law is incredibly precious and to say it
doesn't matter and the police should
walk on by you are playing with fire you
are on the road to anarchy do you sense
that we're in a much more precarious
place right now is that then than we've
ever been or at least more maybe well
the last let's say 50 years something
like that
well we had this extraordinary
revolution that nobody foresaw in the
1990s in the 80s the reigning wisdom and
law enforcement itself was that police
could do nothing about crime that crime
was a product of inequality and
injustice and until you solve poverty
and and economic inequalities all the
police could do would respond after the
fact so why even bother so this is like
why New York City and especially Times
Square was a drug den when I was growing
up going into the city because you just
police were just walking by the FBI
publishes an annual crime report
throughout the 80s they had a disclaimer
saying well of course we know homicide
is a social problem that the police
can't solve so the 90s had this
incredible profound moment where that
whole ideology of passivity before
social Anarchy was turned on its head
and you had mayor Giuliani coming in
Giuliani and his good days I don't know
what's happened to him now it's very
depressing to me but he was the great
one of the greatest mayors if not the
greatest mayor in New York ever had and
his Police Commissioner William Bratton
said no we are actually gonna the police
are gonna lower crime by enforcing the
law and we learned that enforcement
matters you change people's behavior you
deter criminal offending and they
started paying attention to those
low-level crimes in in Times Square the
squalor the the the turnstile jumping
that graffiti the urinating in the
streets and they changed public norms
and and the whole broken windows theory
is correct and even if it doesn't
prevent higher-level crimes it's what
people in high crime neighborhoods beg
for they want public order on the
streets and now that is all being thrown
away and again the reason is disparate
so alright so as someone that deals in
fact and that's what your books have
been about and that's why my audience
digs what you do do you ever find that
sometimes facts just aren't enough to
change the discourse so it's like
alright well then okay we could probably
move on nobody so how do you how do you
deal with that because I find this to be
like the most sort of strangest place
for conservatives to be right now which
is that most of the facts seem to be on
the conservative side of things at the
moment like it just seems to be reality
right now but I think conservatives have
a really hard time breaking through
either the cultural part I think that's
actually really changing right now
partially because of Trump but sometimes
facts just aren't enough right I mean I
was telling you right when you sat down
my we were talking out the homeless
thing the target that's a half mile from
my house there is a massive homeless
encampment massive I mean it's like a
city there now when I go to Target and
it's like well I we could talk about why
some of the reasons that you just laid
out are allowing this to expand but a
lot of people don't want to hear that
well you know this is something that you
have been thinking about for much longer
than I have of how do you change minds
what is the nature of rational discourse
what is its limits and you know we learn
from people like Jonathan hate that in
fact Reason often acts as a
after-the-fact justification for
people's instinctive value systems and
ways of looking at the world so well I
would like to claim non ironically that
I have the facts on my side and the fact
I believe that I mean that's what drives
me and it's sort of a hatred of what I
call idiocy I have to acknowledge that
the progressives would say the same
thing if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell